hello everyone and welcome back to the
opera euro rapid tournament we are in
the third
day uh of the third uh game and it's uh
ding liran
versus magnus carls and it's been a
while since we've seen a game by ding so
very happy to check up on what's what's
he been up to and now
magnus is leading the tournament he has
the black pieces against ding
and in this game he decides to go uh
full barbarian mode against
ding and well let's just see what
happens so uh being with the white
pieces
opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6 by
magnus
c4 e6 knight to f3 and now
a6 magnus goes for the gingi ashwili uh
indian defense or the genji indian
uh we have knights to c3 and now bishop
to b4
so just developing pieces we have bishop
to g5
and now h6 chasing back the bishop
bishop to h4
and now there are a few moves that were
played in this position but the move
magnus plays is a new move
so let's see what happens here it is as
of move seven that we have a completely
new game or rather as of move six he
plays b6
uh and e3 now uh being prepares to
develop his light square bishop with
bishop to b7 and
bishop to d3 and now the
magnus is doing very well in development
he already developed the light square
bishop the dark square bishop
but he will not uh he's a down a temple
so he will not be gaining control of the
e4 square
uh so dean will not be gaining control
of the e4 square and now magnus
eliminates uh on c3 to make sure of that
so characters captures
and now he has control of the e4 square
for the moment
so d6 we have castles knight to b7
and now knight to d2 here ding is
preparing uh to push f4
uh but magnus uh doesn't like that so he
pushes g5 instead
it weakens the king's side and it's not
at all clear now where magnus will
go with his king maybe queen to e7
followed by castles on the queen side
uh who knows maybe the king will remain
in the center of the board so here
g5 bishop back to g3 and now even
h5 by magnus so going for barbarian mode
now preparing to trap that bishop with
h4
so h3 biting uh making some room for the
bishop and the now
h4 uh so the bishop is under attack
bishop to h2 and
now magnus goes uh forward with g4
so it's a it's it's a just a pawn
sacrifice to open up the g
file he is preparing to play queen e7
castles queen side and then bring the
other rook into the game
ending of course accepts this because
there's really no other option you do
not allow g captures on h3 to ever
happen so here
h captures on g4 uh h3 by magnus now
hoping to open up the h file but the
ding says
nope we're just going to play g3 and now
uh being won a pawn but
he has a bishop here on h2 stuck and
it's unclear
when this bishop will come into the game
so it is a
it is a pawn sacrifice and the computers
really don't like carlson's decision
but uh you know uh it's often hard to
evaluate when this bishop will be able
to come into play
and is uh is white even better here so
let's see what happens
uh we have rook to g8 now going after
the g4 pawn
and dink defends it with f3 we have
queen to e7
magnus now preparing to castle queenside
and e4 now by ding
uh we have castle's queen side and now
rook to f2
probably to take control of the second
rank and then it's going to be easy to
either shift this rook to f1
or maybe get this rook to b1 and this
rook to b2 so you can
double up on either side of the board
depending on what magnus plays
so here we have knight back to h7 and
now comes
a4 so going uh after that queen side
a5 is an idea c5 is an idea so a lot of
breakthroughs here are possible so
magnus prevents the a51
but now uh before striking with c five
ding first wants to prepare it so he
goes
uh rook to b1 we have rook d the e8 by
magnus
and now comes knight to f1 here uh
the there was the possibility of playing
e5
right away because the knight on h7 is
undefended for some reason ding didn't
like this maybe maybe because of maybe
f6 and then after capture
for example c captures uh it seems that
black is is kind of holding but it looks
it looks incredibly difficult to hold
this knight stuck
defending this the queen defending the
knight here so the bishop cannot capture
but but c5
it just feels like c5 will just break
through the position and when this
bishop comes alive once you start
pushing some of those pawns
uh if this was of course a classical
position uh ding would not
hesitate a second but as it is a rapid
game you can't afford all that much time
to calculate
uh ding says okay we we always have this
breakthrough is in the position so let's
just keep it solid so knights to f1
and now magnus decides to sacrifice the
pawn with
f5 he wants to open up some lights
towards ding's king
we have e captures that's not an e e
captures on e5
e captures and bishop captures on f5 and
now king to b8
maybe could be an idea as you don't want
this knight pinned forever
but magnus just goes in with knight to
g5
so let's see what happens here ding goes
for c5
again there there's a constantly a theme
in this game where f4 can be played
because
where are you going with this knight
that's the question and the problem with
knights to e4
although uh black has control of the e4
square is that rook to e2
and now what do you play here uh the
knight is definitely
in not in a favorable position the rook
is facing the queen so after queen f7
you're gonna play queen c2 add a third
attacker here and now after knight f6
you're going to play rook
b to e1 and you're going to now control
the e file it's going to be a very
strong position for white but again
a lot to consider here it's a rapid game
so now ding goes for it with c5 he says
there's time for for that uh so magnus
goes king to b8 on pins here so now the
knight is defending the b
pawn and here just c captures on b6 we
have knight captures on b6
and now d5 dink closes up carlson's
light square bishop
i will however mention that there was
the very interesting c4 idea here now
just preparing to completely
shatter uh carlson's queen side and the
idea is that if the
knight is accepted then f4 is truly
truly amazing for example knight e4
rookie 2
goes after the knight and after d5
defending now queen to b3
threatening checkmate and after you
defend against checkmate now bishop
captures the
captures and now knight the e3 and again
we have uh we can triple here on the b
file uh we can play knight knight to c4
uh there are a lot of
possibilities here and it's just going
to be a a very nice attack for
affording but okay ding says there's
always time for that let's not over
calculate he plays d5
and now bishop to a6 and uh time wise uh
dink has some eight minutes and 30
seconds on the clock whereas carlson has
five minutes on the clock so let's see
what happens here
we have queen to d4 biting now with the
idea of playing rook captures here and
just
shattering the queen side maybe not
right away maybe you want to
prepare it a little bit more bring this
rook into the game as well
uh and here queen to g7 would in fact be
a
plausible uh defensive idea now you
don't really gain anything by capturing
because after all the trades here
uh after all the trades happen captures
captures and captures there is still
queen
b7 defending so it's not a problem so
here after queen to d4 this was possible
but magnus decides to defend with king
to a7 now he can also bring the rooks to
help out with the defense
but now it is a lost position for magnus
and it's
actually lost in one move so feel free
to pause the video
and win this game for ding while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh
uh you know spotting that uh win in one
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
it's actually f4 and f4 just uh
you know uh completely destroys black
you never want to go back with knight
stage seven if you go knight back to h7
then it's just uh you know free free
mounting for white rook f2 b2 going
after rook captures knight
and now there's not much to be done here
rook goes here
and then you can start pushing those
pawns g5
and so on not not a move here for for
for black to be made and it's just going
to be a very very slow death for black
so instead magnus decided to go for
knight to e4
sort of a bit of a more active move but
now i don't even have to tell you what
being played
of course being pinned the knight and
now there is no way for you to add any
more defenders so here magnus just went
for knight captures on f2
and he sacrificed his queen for an
attempt
at a mating attack dingo force accepts
the queen we have rook captures on e7
and now a very important uh move by ding
do not capture with the queen if you
capture with the queen then magnus
indeed has
rook to e2 and now after the queen moves
uh you're gonna get rooked to e1 and now
white is in a lot of trouble here
because magnus is now threatening rook
captures with checkmate
and you would have to you know try try
something like king h1 give up the
knight so you have defense with bishop
to g1 that's very ugly
so instead ding played king captures on
f2 and now you are
most certainly defending magnus played
rook to e2 check
king of three and now rook g to e8
but here ding said uh that's really not
not much of a problem
uh we have bishop to d3 he wants to
eliminate carlson's very strong bishop
here
bishop captures queen captures and now
comes rook to g2 by magnus saying that
okay
maybe now your pieces are a bit tied
down maybe i can bring my rook to e2
but here dean just looked at the
position he played g5
and he was in this position on move 36
that magnus carlsen resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
those pawns are just marching forward
and any idea here uh doesn't really work
there's no way for you to bring any of
your pieces into
into the game uh so i don't know yeah
if you try something like this to
deliver checkmate here it's
it simply doesn't work because white
would happily give up the queen for both
rooks
and then you just push the g pawn to
victory so as there is nothing more to
be done here
magnus resigns and a brilliant victory
for ding liran
against world champion magnus carlson
but i i i thought it was just uh
really funny and it's so great that of
course magnus is already qualified for
the main event
and he can just you know afford to go
all out with the black pieces against uh
such a monster like being lyran uh and
then we get exciting
games like this so very very happy that
you know everyone is in good spirits
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game hope
you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank sebastian von
hick uh girl gerald watts uh forrest
williams diego barrero and joseph
bassette for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
at continuing the coverage of this very
nice event checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world uh so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day